originally from Monrovia California I've
been playing games since I can remember
and I started actually doing recording
my game play on VHS I'd like to be
considered as an entertainer I like to
entertain people and with gaming that
was an outlet for me when I was done
with school I'd come home and just
record my best gameplay my speedruns it
never occurred to me that you know I
could do gaming as a main thing or as a
career but it wasn't so recently when I
actually got off to clash of clans and
mobile gaming that it took off and I got
partnered with a company and they took
in and clash of clans is a game where
they were pretty much the first one
there have that aspect where you're
building you're upgrading and you're
coming back and you know it's a repeat
process where you're getting in the game
and you're involved and you have a
community as well I was a youtuber prior
to being a clash of clans player and I
got dropped back into it because of the
game and I was looking for things on
YouTube for advice and tips and I just
didn't see what I was looking for and so
I decided you know what I have something
that I want to give to the community to
people out there that don't know about
this yet so I decided hey you know I'm a
just get back into youtube and post
on a good day I have a hundred thousand
people you know check out a video that I
do so it's really like mind boggling
like is there that many people that have
looked at my video and it's just a
numbers thing for me it's really
humbling to have that many people you
know look at your content I would say
clash of Clan has definitely changed my
life for the better now I can honestly
do what I loved before
you know I was being successful on
YouTube I was doing this you know
without any recognition or anything so
now clash of clans has given me that
opportunity to be a youtuber and to have
a sort of following and a fan base so I
would say definitely it's changed me